Wonderful.
Professor David Demarest,
thank you so much for being
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Happy to be here.
Such an honor to have you here.
You know you are one of my
favorite, favorite professors
of my one year at Stanford,
but I'm sure looking back
at the four years
you're still gonna be
one of my favorite professors
because the amount of inspiration
that you gave me and
I think 19 others in the class
is just unparalleled to
what we could have hoped for.
Professor Demarest, you were
one of the head of communications
for the George Bush Sr. administration
in the White House.
Bank of America, Visa with branding
and communications
and an expert on strategy.
I just wanna hear stories
over these 20 minutes and hear,
you know, some of the incredible
lessons that you taught us.
Professor, can you tell me a little bit
about where you came from
and how you even got to be
in communications
for George Bush Senior?
Well, I have been active in politics
generally, for a number of years.
Helping to rebuild what was then
a struggling political party,
meaning the Republican Party
in the late 70s
and had some success doing that.
Reagan was elected in 1980.
And my boss, who was the chairman
of the Republican Party,
became the U.S. trade representative.
And he asked me to come run
public affairs for that cabinet agency.
And that started a career in government
that went on for about 12 years.
But there was one break,
and that was when I had the opportunity
to be Communications Director
for the first President Bush's
presidential campaign in '88.
And it was an absolute honor
to work for him, but also
to play on a national stage.
I had been Assistant Secretary of Labor.
I had a long career in politics
and government, as I mentioned,
but having the opportunity
to work at that level,
nationally was really very exciting.
I'm sure. Yeah.
And then he won.
And I went into the White House
as the White House's
communications director.
It was a wild ride.
And I think one of the things that
I took from that
was to always maintain
your perspective that this
was not a permanent job.
The White House careers
rise and fall overnight.
You have to be able to accept that.
The demands on your time
and your energy are extraordinary.
You have to be able to accept that.
But throughout it all,
I think one of the things that served me
very well was that I never sort of
took that job as an entitlement.
That it was a job that I
was privileged to have.
I was privileged to serve
President Bush,
but I knew that
it was going to end
at some point
whether it was gonna
to be two years, three years,
four years, eight years,
whatever it was gonna be.
It was gonna be over.
And I couldn't let myself think
that that was my kind of my life.
And I think keeping things
in perspective like that
helped me when
he did not win his re-election.
I was out of work for eight months.
And it never really
caused me significant distress.
And I think about what's happening today
with all the dislocation
that people are undergoing.
It's heartbreaking
in many cases.
People are losing their businesses,
or their livelihoods.
But this, too, shall pass.
And if you look at the positives
that have come from this,
people that I have talked with and,
I acknowledge that I am privileged
and have some resources.
But the time I've been able to spend
with my family has been extraordinary.
The time that I've had to think about
the next phase of my teaching
has been a godsend.
Just the ability to kind of reflect
and sit back and take it all in
and think about next steps.
You know, looking at all of this
not as a threat,
but an opportunity
I think is incredibly important.
So professor, what I
of course forgot to mention,
which I tried to imply,
was that you're a
distinguished professor of the
Stanford Business School.
I got to take a class with you
as an undergraduate
because you so kindly
agreed to teach an undergraduate
class on strategy.
And really you could replace
the name strategy with the name
context between us, correct?
But I think it's an incredible
... what's happening today.
But I have to know,
you're in the White House.
How often do you go
into the Oval Office?
How often do you interact
with President Bush?
And what is that
sense of responsibility feel like
when you know that
you're at a position
that perhaps every American,
most Americans can't even imagine
to be sitting where you're sitting?
Well, you know,
it's an incredible honor.
I probably went into the Oval Office
to meet with the president
every other day.
Wow.
Now, having said that,
the first time I went
into the Oval Office, when he
called me in to work on a speech,
he didn't like the speech
that had been delivered to him
and he wanted,
he was uncomfortable with it.
Yeah.
And I got this call saying the president
wants to see you in the Oval Office.
Well, of course, my heart started thumping.
And I walk in and I sit down
and he starts saying,
"I'm not sure the speech
hits all the right notes.
I know a lot of these people.
A lot of 'em are friends of mine."
These were CEOs that he was
going to be talking to at a luncheon.
And he says, "The
they probably are doing a lot of the
community activities already.
I don't want to talk down to them"
Meanwhile, I'm sitting there and I'm
looking around the room thinking,
"Holy mackerel, I am in the Oval Office"
He then says, "Okay?"
And I realized the meeting is over.
And I haven't heard a thing he said.
And I couldn't very well say to him,
"You know, I really wasn't
paying much attention
because I was so overwhelmed
by looking at the grandfather clock
and the two seats where the heads
of state sit and the oval rug
with the presidential
seal on it and all that"
And so, I got up and I walked out
and I thought to myself,
"I am screwed.
I have no idea how to make
this speech right."
And it's a longer story than that,
but you know,
I've taken major celebrities
into the Oval Office
to meet with the president.
And they, too, are awed.
I took Michael Jackson
into the Oval Office.
You know, the gloved one.
Right.
You walked next to Michael Jackson
and ushered him
into the Oval Office.
I did.
And it was a very bizarre meeting.
And it was just,
it was surreal,
is what it was. But -
How does that even work?
So somebody says, somebody who is well known
and has a lot of impact
can just say,
"Hey, I wanna meet with the president.
Get me an hour in the Oval Office"?
No, it doesn't quite work that way.
I had, one of my staff had heard
from Michael Jackson's people
that he wanted to see
the Lincoln Bedroom.
He wanted to visit the White House
and see the Lincoln Bedroom.
And we then said let's up this and
have him do a photo with the
president in the Oval Office.
Well, little did I know
that he was going to bring
a big entourage with him.
And so, I had to cleave
the entourage from him
and I made him come up
and meet with me in my office first.
That was sort of a bizarre meeting.
And then I didn't ever let him
link back up with his entourage
and just took him
and his manager into the Oval Office.
This is just incredible.
He didn't exactly connect
with the president.
But he did connect with Mrs. Bush.
And it was a very
interesting interaction.
Wow.
What I didn't know,
and this was the mischievous part
of President Bush,
as he's in the Oval Office, he says
"Now Michael, we're gonna go out and do
what we call a photo opportunity."
Like Michael didn't know what that was.
"We're gonna go out into the Rose Garden
and I'm gonna have a few remarks
about Mr. Gorbachev."
And the press secretary
and myself are thinking, "What?
He's gonna walk out
into the Rose Garden
where there's this enormous
gaggle of reporters
with Michael Jackson
and he's gonna talk about Gorbachev?"
He walks out into the Oval,
into the Rose Garden,
and he announces the first
summit meeting with the Soviet Union.
Standing with Michael Jackson.
It was a surreal moment
beyond surreal moments.
And all we could think of,
and Marlin Fitzwater the press secretary
got into a kind of a giggle about it,
was that we imagined the KGB
watching us and trying to figure out
why is he announcing this
with Michael Jackson?
What is the significance of this?
And we got quite a kick out of it.
That's just incredible.
And then it was just pure George Bush
Of course. Of course.
OK, Professor Demarest, moving on.
You're Director
of Communications and Branding at
two of the most incredible corporations
that really have both critical
infrastructure in our daily lives
but it really changed the way we
interact with our financial institutions
and with responsibilities greater
than just financial institutions.
Some of the case studies
that we've studied in our class
from your positions there just showed us
how these corporations,
their impact goes far beyond just
the exchange of money
and storing our money.
That's Bank of America
and Visa of course.
So what did you learn
running communications and branding
for these incredible incredible companies?
Well, I think the biggest learning
that I had from that experience
was to understand that brand
is much more than just a logo.
Brand is much more than a presentation.
Brand is really about a promise.
And it's a promise to customers.
It could be a promise to the community.
It could be a promise about
social responsibility.
All large, impactful organizations
make promises to a wide
range of constituencies.
Right.
And their reputation is dependent upon
whether those constituencies
to whom the promise is made
believe that it has been a promise kept.
And so, it's changed my thinking about
how to understand reputation,
how to understand brand,
and in a much the lens that I look
at at brand is a much wider lens
than it was previously.
Right.
The other thing I think I learned
primarily at the latter stage
of my corporate career was
how important strategic thinking is.
Yes.
And the ability to think strategically.
And what are the ingredients
for strategic thinking.
And you mentioned context.
That is a key ingredient.
A rigorous understanding of context
and then understanding how one
action creates another action -
Talk to me a little bit about this.
Talk to me about this little,
about this chess game of understanding.
Because throughout the course,
almost at every case study,
we understood in hindsight
that if we could just think
a little bit further ahead
and play this chess game internally
and realize
There were some instances where
we were amazed by how you
realized back then
in 1970 that one action
is gonna lead to another,
and you were able to save
six months of hardships
and hundreds of millions of dollars.
How can we possibly do that?
Sit down and try to imagine
what the possible scenarios are
so that we can avoid
the hardships already?
Yeah, I think one of the words
you just used is critical.
Imagine, you have to have
a flourishing and
thriving imaginary
imagination capability.
Right.
And that comes with test driving ideas.
It comes with
not letting the emperor walk around
with no clothes.
Right.
It comes with defining reality.
Looking at things with a critical eye.
You know, if you look at what's happened
today with this whole pandemic,
there was a lot of
a distinct lack of thinking ahead
and thinking about consequence
and the absence of defining what was reality.
All these mixed messages that have
come out for the last six months
have been incredibly destructive
to having a coherent strategy.
And so, I think that the idea of
really getting ingrained in your head
that everything you do
is gonna have a consequence,
and that consequence is
gonna have a consequence,
and so forth and so forth and so forth.
And the more you're able to take those steps,
the further you take those steps,
the more you're going to land
on the right landing zone
that is going to be the most positive.
Sure. And you know,
all these are leadership positions
that you have quite a few people
under you.
And a lot of these times
it sounds like
they're more crisis management
than they are just thinking
strategically. Right?
Because every time you're confronted
with a communications crisis or
a branding crisis,
you're the go to guy and says,
"David, please help us solve this.
This is your time to shine."
How do you go about doing that?
I mean, how is leading in a crisis
different than
leading when times are good
and you're just thinking about
the next nice project to do?
Well, you know,
as you heard me say in class,
the best crisis management is to avert
the crisis in the first place.
And so,
that means a lot of thinking about
where are the potential crises.
Right.
You know, they're all out there.
There are all these landmines out there,
and if you're able to identify them early,
you can navigate them
with more skill.
However, that doesn't mean to say
that you can avoid every crisis.
Right.
I think the important thing
in crisis management,
well there's several things.
One is something called
deliberate calmness.
You have to create an environment
for yourself that is deliberately calm
so that you can ask the right questions.
Right.
And a lot of times in a crisis,
you'll watch people run around
thinking that,
What are we gonna do?
And they haven't asked
the most important question,
which we said a lot in class,
which is,
Okay, what do we know?
What do we know about the circumstance?
And what do we need to know?
Exactly.
And so, if we ask the right questions
and we do so in a thoughtful, calm,
organized way,
you will not only be able to navigate
through the moment,
but you'll also be able to understand
what the ramifications are longer term.
McKinsey calls that integrative thinking.
The kind of thinking that you can
simultaneously think about
what you have to do in the moment
at the same time you're thinking
about the implications for the future.
And that's what we really needed
in this current environment
were people that could do that.
I think it's incredible.
I mean, every time we walked into class
and we received the case study
ahead of time and we were so
pumped we would discuss it for hours.
My good friend Santiago and I
before coming to class,
and we come in and all of a sudden you say,
"Okay, wait, wait, stop.
What do you know?
What do you need to know?"
And then we, and then
the second half was only
Okay, how can we now use this information
to process through this?
But it's not just jumping in
and with the first instinct, just acting.
Professor, you are looking at now
you know this global pandemic.
It was, at least to me,
very apparent in the tech community
that almost every company
and every institution decided
to deal with things differently.
Also in terms of universities.
You have universities that have,
that until today have not decided
on what's happening next year.
You have universities that
have already decided
that they're closed next year
for physical studies.
And you have universities that
have already said they're open.
So, it sounds like globally
there's not really strategic strategy
for communicating with the public.
Of course, looking at governments,
it's very similar.
What's your take on this?
What does it take from a government
or an institution to power through
a crisis that we just don't know what it is?
We just don't know what the ending is.
Well, first of all, you have to communicate
coherently and consistently.
and that includes communicating
what you don't know.
Okay.
And I think that early on
there were a lot of leaders,
I won't get into too many specifics,
but there were a lot of leaders
who communicated about things
they knew nothing about.
Right.
And made assertions and comments
that were confusing to the public.
You had some leaders,
and I would say
some of the governors,
I think showed incredible
forthrightness and calm.
And I think somebody like
Governor Cuomo in New York.
Every day -
Very impressive. Yes.
briefing and saying
what they know, what don't know,
what are the practical steps,
what are the responsible steps.
He also was a moral leader
about what were people's responsibilities.
Yes.
And he practiced what he preached.
All of those things go into
having an ability to mobilize
not just public opinion,
but public action.
And so that people weren't
demonstrating in the streets.
They weren't resisting
what was calm
and deliberative leadership.
Definitely.
I mean, you look at New Zealand
just as another case study.
- Exactly
... see the prime minister
standing every day.
And I watched quite a few of those
because I was just inspired
every time she had a question
and then she looked to the doctor
on her right and said
"I don't know this.
Do you know this?"
Let's write it down.
Let's check on this
and we'll come back to you tomorrow."
And the next day she
would come back to it.
That's leadership to me.
The leadership taking ownership
of what you know,
what you don't know
and over communicating
not under communicating.
I talked to quite a few, through this show,
I talked to quite a few
CEOs of companies
both large and small
And one thing that
constantly came up
is this idea of always
overcommunicate.
Never under communicate,
especially in a time of crisis.
That trust that you're building,
and I think we talked about this
quite a bit about
in the context of branding.
It's you gain the trust
along the way
with the actions you do.
It's very easy to break the trust.
To do a single, right?
Yeah. Well, and you know,
the other thing is that
now more than ever,
given that communications
don't take place in a vacuum,
there is this communications environment
that we live in today
of social media
and highly partisan media
that is out there
fomenting misinformation,
disinformation.
Some of it's accurate information,
but how do you know?
How do you tell the difference?
Well, that's where you need
government leaders, corporate leaders
to be more thoughtful
so that they can command
the public's attention.
When they're sending mixed messages,
who does the public turn to
for an authoritative source?
There is no one.
Definitely. It's incredible.
Professor, right before we leave,
I wanna get your overall insight.
I'm looking at myself as
a young entrepreneur.
I am very excited to one day
start my company, hopefully
sooner rather than later.
I am even more excited to be
in one of your classes,
hopefully as a GSB student
myself one day.
But if you could give me one or two
key pieces of advice looking forward
from your enormous career
both in corporate
and the public service,
but also at Stanford
which you ran communications
which I didn't even mention.
What should I take with me
over my next few decades as
I aim to be a leader myself?
I think about three things.
And, you know, I think best in three's
One is always find your colleagues,
people that you're working with,
that are worthy of respect.
You want to work with people
that you respect.
Right.
Second, always find something
that allows you to grow
Intellectually, perhaps financially,
but most importantly,
that is going to drive
your intellectual curiosity
and keep it vibrant and thriving.
And finally,
knowing you as I do,
I think I would say
always make sure you're involved
in something beyond yourself.
So that it's bigger than you.
And that will, I think, give your life
and your career
that much more purpose.
I love it.
And definitely, I think having this
one on one here
and everything that I've
learned from you and
I wanna thank you again
for the incredible, incredible course
that you taught us
and for all the inspiration.
I think that it's one thing as a class
to come in and show you
that we're learning
and that we're progressing
and we are enjoying it.
But I have to tell you that outside
of the classroom,
the number of meaningful discussions
we've had and the thoughts we shared
on how inspiring this was,
it really, I think,
changed a lot of our thinking
in the context of what it means to be
a person who thinks strategically,
a person who looks at a problem,
and understands that it's bigger
than just the hundred words
written on the page.
Context is everything.
It's all about what we don't know
as much as we what we know
and what do we need to know
in order to feel comfortable
solving the puzzle.
So, thank you very much.
Right before we leave.
Three words that best describe you.
Optimistic.
Principled.
Yeah.
And determined.
I love it.
Professor Demarest,
thank you very, very much.
Enjoy your time in Florida.
Enjoy your time with your family,
and I look forward to seeing you
on campus one day in person.
You take care, Michael.
Take care.
Thank you for the time.